joining us now from Detroit is Susan Tom
poor she is a personal finance columnist
with the Detroit Free Press Detroit Free
Press rather talking to us about federal
aid to the auto industry good morning
and welcome to the program good morning
thank you the headline the big story in
the in this morning's edition of the
Detroit Free Press on the front page it
says Detroit's new plan drive a point to
Congress what is it that the automakers
want Congress to understand about this
situation out there in Detroit well I
think the automakers want Congress to
understand and I might add Michigan
would like Congress to understand that
the auto industry is a critical part of
the US economy what's important to
understand here is we we're now into the
17th nearing the 17th month of a credit
crunch this has not just been a problem
with a recession we have a very severe
financial crisis one of the worst since
the Great Depression autos typically are
bought on credit people don't buy cash
for a $30,000 we don't spend cash on a
$30,000 vehicle so what the auto
industry really needs Congress to
understand is that there are loans that
they would like Congress to to make to
the auto industry and last week was
pretty much I don't want to say a fiasco
but it was a fiasco in Washington when
you have Saturday Night Live parroting
the three CEOs speaking before the
Senate before the house that's not a
good sign we're going to show what
really happened in front of the House
Financial Services Committee with the
heads of Chrysler GM and Ford I want to
get your comment on that when we come
back we're asking for assistance for one
reason to address the devastating
automotive industry recession caused by
our nation's financial meltdown with
credit markets frozen the average
working American can't get competitive
financing to purchase or lease vehicles
our dealers many of whom are in the room
with me today don't have access to
market competitive funding to place
wholesale orders for new vehicles which
result in the constrict
of cash inflow to all of us as auto
manufacturers at the same time
Chrysler's has Chrysler has billions of
dollars in cash payment obligations to
pay wages to pay suppliers to fund
healthcare and Pensions all in the range
of four to five billion dollars a month
mr. chairman I do not agree with those
who say we are not doing enough to
position GM for success what exposes us
to failure now is not our product line
up nor our business plan nor our
long-term strategy what exposes us to
fail you now is the global financial
crisis which is severely restricted
credit availability and reduced industry
sales to the lowest per capita level
since World War two our industry needs a
bridge to span the financial chasm that
is open before us will use this bridge
to pay for essential operations new
vehicles and power trains parts from our
suppliers wages and benefits for our
workers and retirees and taxes for state
and local government there are two
fundamental questions today first is
there a competitive and sustainable
future for our domestic automobile
industry and second is a government
bridge loan through these difficult
economic times better for our country
than in action I believe the answer to
both of these questions is yes Susan
Tom poor now that the leaders of the
three automotive companies are back in
Detroit what is their plan and what what
was the reaction first in Detroit to the
testimony on Capitol Hill in Michigan
and in Detroit specifically and what's
their leaders plan what are they working
on now to try and get more cooperation
from Congress well I think the summaries
that you gave here are very good and
they were very succinct unfortunately I
don't think that was the message that
people took home of those summaries all
three CEOs sounded perfectly reasonable
in what they had just said they
summarized it very well however that
isn't the message that Congress ended up
hearing you know that isn't the message
that the committees were hearing again
as I said Saturday Night Live ended up
parroting these companies and the reason
they did that is because they're going
back to some of the old
cliches the old standards of the 1970s
1980s industry this is an industry that
has cut back severely it will still need
to cut back but it does need as CEO Rick
Wagner from GM said this bridge to get
through this crunch that is the message
I think they're going to try to give the
Detroit Free Press also reported today
that there's some talk of perhaps having
a rally here in Hart Plaza a caravan if
you will to show that the auto industry
is taking green very seriously
there are hybrids they're not just the
Toyota Prius isn't the only hybrid on
the road today the Chevrolet Malibu from
General Motors has a hybrid there is a
Chevrolet Saturn with a hybrid Saturn
Vue many many hybrids out there Ford has
hybrids in its fusion so that you know
there's going to be some effort to show
here that the industry is serious about
going green there's a lot of bad a bad
feeling in the country I think you know
Senator Carl Levin is optimistic I think
when he says that there's an
understanding that there's a need here
to fix this problem from the emails I'm
getting from people from what I'm
hearing from what I'm seeing on
television this I'm not clear in my own
mind that everyone understands there is
a need I think there's a lot of
animosity toward the big three toward
the UAW I don't know how you overcome
that but they need a plan right now
the CEOs were told to come up with a
plan by December 2nd come back to
Congress December 8th but it isn't just
a plan to show how they're gonna pay
back the money and they do need to show
that there's no bank in the country
that's going to give a loan to anyone
without showing at least one or two ways
of how you're gonna pay back that money
that's serious that's obvious but the
problem is a perception problem there a
problem is a lot of people don't like
the auto industry the the American auto
industry and that is I don't know how
you fix that very quickly but that is
job one that they're going to have to
fix really quickly and and put it
seriously seriously on the table before
we go to the callers the lead story in
the Detroit Free Press this morning with
the headline 11:00 once Obama to
helped president-elect should support
auto industry auto loans the senator
says what is it that the senator is
looking for the president-elect to do
that Congress can't or may not want to
do well I think the president-elect has
a lot of right now he's he's still in
good standings right we just a you know
the country just elected him so he still
uh still has a good reputation I think
he wants someone to kind of bring it all
together I think you know senator Levin
is saying that he believes that this
could get done but obviously you know we
need more help
he needs more help in convincing people
that that this loan needs to be made
it is possible perhaps to free up some
of the money that's already been offered
as part of an energy retooling package
it's also possible some are talking
about taking out of the 700 billion and
maybe carving some of that money out for
the auto industry it's a complicated
issue because we are in a financial
crisis that is why the auto industry is
here yes they've had problems but this
is a financial crisis we have the issue
with Citigroup so you know it's a very
expensive issue a lot of people were not
that excited about the Wall Street
bailout we can't forget that people
people don't like CEOs being bailed out
but but in essence CEOs aren't the only
ones being bailed out this weekend I
talked to a gentleman who has a fast
food restaurant or you know works with
some fast food restaurants chain one of
these restaurants happens to be near a
Ford plant here he said to me every time
they talk about shutting down that Ford
plant and that pork plant is still
running by the way but every time they
talk about it 10% of the sales at a
fast-food restaurant go down this is
fast food this is not a high ticket item
and and I was kind of shocked I said you
know who stops eating fast food because
they think well maybe there'll be
layoffs but people do stop eating fast
food people do stop buying people do
stop shopping I think one of the big
dangers here is the longer we talk about
this bailout in any case the longer the
fear factor keeps going the more people
shut down and stop spending one thing
that people have talked about is the
pearls along the highway in terms of
these suppliers if you drive up up and
down
five there's all sorts of supplier jobs
direct suppliers to the carmaker's but
then there are food companies there are
restaurants there are stores that sell
to those people who work at these
supplier companies many of the supplier
companies not only supply the big three
they also supply Honda Toyota and some
of the other manufacturers here in the
United States we have just-in-time
inventory that so there are not like
auto suppliers just sitting here you
know waiting if there are problems with
General Motors and Ford and this is why
or Chrysler this is why you have all of
the big three together those suppliers
are very key and they are also very key
to the other manufacturers in this
country such as Toyota and Honda let's
take some calls if you want to get
involved in the conversation with Susan
Tom poor of the Detroit Free Press
Democrats can call us at 2:02 7:37
triple zero two Republicans two zero two
737 triple zero one independents two
zero two six two eight zero two zero
five our first call comes from Canton
Ohio on our line for Democrats good
morning yeah I'm post-world War two the
greatest generation basically used the
labor unions to tame the corrupt
politicians in corporations and what
they did is they created a economic
system that basically will go down in
history as the greatest economy in the
history of mankind what what they did is
they created a system where consumers
and producers were matched there was a
million workers at General Motors at one
time every one of those workers bought
cars wild reagan comes into office and
he starts the supply-side economics the
new world order globalization and what
he does is immediately separate
consumers from producers he sent jobs
from Chrysler that China where people
are making 50 cents an hour 30 years
later here we are with the the the
biggest economic meltdown since 1929 not
based on General Motors business model
it's
some supply-side economics based on
globalization in fact what we're talking
about is fascism we're talking about
class warfare you have 400 families 4
worth 1.25 billion dollars you have
hedge fund managers making fix or making
a billion dollars a year when when Bush
took office
thank you sir we're gonna leave it there
Susan Tom poor did you want to respond
well I think one number that we need to
focus on right now is we're talking
about two hundred and fifty five
thousand jobs in the big three that does
not sound like a lot but there are
estimates that if the big three would
completely fold up you know which is not
going to happen but if it did overnight
that that would impact three million
jobs down the line because of the
suppliers so we still have a
manufacturing base here in this country
Toyota is doing some research and
development here in Michigan a thirty
engineering jobs we have the talent we
have a base that that many people feel
is need protecting because these
manufacturing jobs are good they are not
all Union jobs many non unions auto
supplier jobs are at stake here
obviously non-union jobs in the fast
food industry and some of the retail
sectors that would be impacted here
banking is also an area that there's
more discussion now about how that would
be impacted there are different numbers
that you're seeing in terms of how many
loans are outstanding directly to the
automakers as well as to the suppliers
there is some inference here that the
banking industry the financial sector
would take another hit
how how significant that is hard to say
obviously people who lose their jobs in
the auto industry are going to have a
hard time paying their mortgage we have
a financial crisis that also has a
housing crisis involved so this is going
to add further pressure on you know
people paying paying their homes you
know their mortgage paying off their
homes
adding to the foreclosure pressure here
in Michigan and we've already seen that
Michigan has been in a recession for
quite some time several years so we
already have a high foreclosure rate
that I would imagine that would increase
if we do see more of these plants
closing more fear again even these
plants don't have to close but if the
fear continues and there's an unknown
out there the uncertainty is difficult
on the pocketbook let's take this call
from Belleville New Jersey on our line
for Republicans yeah yeah you try to get
this extinct I'm hearing from mr. Tom
poor that she picks up on the animosity
that's unwarranted by the consumer
against the auto industry now in a way I
understand her everybody was wrong
Horne management let's forget that the
main thing is getting back on our feet
so let's give them money I think yeah
anomalies coming from people like me I'm
a consumer that was bad boy too I've
mismanaged my company me my personal
life I thought I didn't need the HD
television so but twelve thousand
dollars to get me out of my own not
twelve billion and I think that's
because people make mistakes the
millionaires get the money we make
mistake support people we don't get the
money on that one last thing
I watched football big football fan in
any channel especially football I see a
car commercial every other commercial
not to me that looks like a cost money
and they're supposed to be broke thanks
for your call Susan Tom poor the Detroit
Free Press well thank you for that there
are car commercials still on TV but
there are also television stations that
are reporting that the advertising has
been cut back quite a bit I can't
confirm that I've read a report in USA
Today about that that advertising has
been cut back for many of the car
companies but your point on how the
individual feels about these bailouts is
true many people felt that way about the
wall street 700 billion people said well
I put very little down on my home maybe
that was a problem maybe I shouldn't
have done that but I can't sell my home
right now that's a very understandable
concern I mean it that is it's a reality
for many people that they overextended
or maybe they were told that if you put
little down on your home
the equities gonna build and this is a
great investment so yes there's that
animosity as well coupling here and it's
very understandable I don't understand
how Congress wouldn't understand what
the everyday individual who's been
through this financial crisis is feeling
like they maybe they've been sold a bill
of goods we're talking about maybe go
ahead I'm talking about you know that
this housing idea that you could make
lots of money in housing or or you could
cover your retirement with your 401k
plan you know would put more money into
the 401k plan and and you'll be able to
retire at 50 a lot of people feel like
they've been sold a bill of goods in
this country when it comes to their
finances perfectly understandable we're
not we're not where we thought we would
be we're talking about the federal
federal aid to the auto industry with
Susan Tom pora the Detroit Free Press
and our next call comes from Hamilton
Montana good morning good morning Susan
I just want to say can you hear me go
ahead sir me yes
good morning I just want to say that
first gentleman that spoke I thought he
had some information that was gold and I
just would wish you would let him finish
up it was really it was really
interesting we've been begging the the
executives from Detroit auto industry
since I think 72 to raise the cafe
standards if we had the macaws Iceland
is raised maybe we wouldn't had such a
transference of wealth to the oil to the
earth people I would
III hope the other industry survives
it's I remember when it didn't have a
million people working for it I got the
American cars are the greatest cars in
the world I think sir we lost him
Susan Tom poor explained the cafe
standards and how adjusting them might
bring more people back into the
showrooms well there is some effort of
course to get more mileage per gallon
from from the on the cars there is some
some research that says you know we had
these cafes
people are now consuming more fuel than
ever though typically when the cafe
standards went into effect you know 30
years ago that the harbor report Jim
Harbor noted that the idea was to cut
our dependence on fuel you know cut fuel
consumption that didn't happen you know
more people are driving people started
driving bigger vehicles it's it's
difficult I think and this is my opinion
but I think it is difficult to base and
energy policy on the price of fuel
because a couple of months ago were
paying $4 and a quarter for gas people
don't want the big trucks the SUVs at
that point I drove by this morning I saw
gas at a dollar 59 that was with cash
here in Michigan and I'm sure that's not
the cheapest gas station in town this is
in the suburbs so it was a dollar 59 a
couple of months ago it would have been
easily four and a quarter that's hard
that's maybe not the way to build a car
to decide how what the price of gas is
going to be so I think you know the the
trend has to be toward more energy
efficient vehicles anyway whatever the
price of gas is and and more
diversification perhaps and how we
alternative energy type vehicles you're
hearing more from Ford Motor Company on
this issue bill Vlasic in the New York
Times today reported that William Ford
jr. has had contact and talked with
president-elect Obama about energy
policy Ford has you know been trying to
go more green with their hybrids and and
try to of course they also had the f-150
truck out so you know for before critics
say that you know it also sells big
trucks as well but there's a need for
the big truck you know one of the
reasons the big trucks aren't selling is
also because the housing construction
market is down farmers you know people
in contracting need big trucks so there
needs to be a diverse mix of the type of
vehicle sold but we're going off on a
point here that is away from these loans
these loans are necessary because of the
credit crunch these loans are necessary
because of the financial meltdown
Detroit needs to go more green no matter
what that would be the trend
no matter what and that's a necessity no
matter what but this financial loans
that are being talked about and right
now they're being talked about 25
billion in contrast week in Washington
Chrysler said they need seven billion
General Motors said they would need 10
to 12 Ford said it might be 7 to 8 but
Ford is a little bit stronger and says
they won't need the money soon they
won't need it right away they have more
cash on hand those are not issues I
think they get law I think the issue
right now is getting lost with the green
issue oh gosh sorry let's take this call
from Lexington Kentucky on our line for
Democrats I just have a couple general
comments first of all I agree with your
guests
we've got to do something with the
automakers I don't think this can be put
off
I feel like instead of Congress going
home for the holiday break as much as
they should go I think they needed to
stay in Washington and work on this and
furthermore now with the new news with
Citigroup and the financial mess that
they're in we have to get this problem
under control because so many jobs are
going to be lost like a domino effect
and I'm really afraid our economy is
going to go down in flames thank you
before you answer that
Susan Tom poor let me read to you from
an item in The Wall Street Journal this
morning it says that Senator Charles
Schumer plans to send a letter urging
the Federal Reserve to make financing
available for the auto companies lending
arms which would allow them to offer
more auto loans a spokesman for the
senator said the letter will also ask
the Treasury to speed up approval of GM
ac's LLC's request to become a bank
holding company how is that going to
help out the auto industry do you think
well that is another part of the puzzle
you know they have these lending arms
where credit may be freed up one part of
the problem in this is of course
borrowers people who buy cars consumers
are having a hard time getting a car
loan I've written about this in the past
many people are surprised in the past
couple months when they go to buy a car
people who have been able easily able to
get a car loan
in the past have been turned down
perhaps on that first car loan the
dealer then has to shop further down the
line the loan may get done but it is at
a higher higher interest rate a higher
cost to the consumer for some consumers
that still works out fine they can still
buy the vehicle for other consumers who
are on the margin if you will or maybe a
casual shopper thinking they'll stretch
that car out so that deal isn't going to
get done this might help free up for the
consumer and it might put a floor if you
will under some of the problems with car
sales that would be separate of course
from these loans where companies are
manufacturing a product and need the
money to continue operating and again
the car industry is stressing that they
would you know repay some of these loans
I think it's interesting Kentucky has a
you know plant and Toyota
Kentucky Oda plant in Kentucky rather
and Ford plants in Kentucky General
Motors plant in Kentucky so you know
this is these are other states involved
you know sometimes you just look at the
CEOs from Michigan say it's is just a
Michigan problem no others many other
states are involved in the auto industry
let's take this call from Collierville
Tennessee on our line for Republicans go
ahead yes I just wanted to say that I
think that the problem is not with the
auto industry I think the problem is
that we've had growth leadership
failures from our congressman from our
president this free trade agreement that
we have it's not free to us Susan Tom
poor trades important you know Canada's
also has a big manufacturing facilities
connections to the auto industry trade
is very important to the whole workings
of the industry I'm not so sure I've you
know you you want to start stopping
trade at this point in the game when you
talk about trade it does get complex
because of course jobs are being lost
but you know jobs are also gained we
trade as well with other partners I
think that's very important as well very
quickly Susan Tom poor before we let you
go in The Washington Times this morning
the headline 1979 Chrysler bailout holds
lessons what's the difference between
the situation with the auto industry now
and what happened in 1979 and are there
some lessons that you see that can be
learned to sort of fix the situation and
we find ourselves in today well I think
the one key point in 1979 most cars were
many cars were junk and they still did a
bailout at that time right now many of
the cars are better quality so we
shouldn't go back and think about the
1980s or 1979 with the American
automakers second the money was repaid
with interest Chrysler did it did get
back on its feet
you know repay this money to the federal
government key point here these
automakers are still asking for loans
you know I think that that's important
the money can get repaid and jobs you
know you can still keep some jobs here
so I think that's also very important
the leadership perhaps was a little bit
stronger under that Chrysler bailout one
of the key points there is you know Lee
Iacocca came out very strongly saying
he'd take less money you know he'd cut
his salary we're not seeing that yet
from the CEOs maybe we'll see some more
of that but there were concessions on
all fronts
the UAW came in with concessions on
those bailouts I think that's what we're
gonna probably see you know more talk of
people people making sacrifices to make
sure this job gets done
Susan Tom poor the Detroit Free Press
thank you very much for being on the
program and talking to us about federal
aid to the auto industry thank you we
are gonna take a short break and when we
come back we'll be talking to CNBC's
Larry Kudlow we'll be back in just a few
minutes